bunch of draws
and believe in ding who never wins
though so far
it was funny that i was discussing with
some friends yesterday i was
visiting some people and then they tell
me what do i think about rockwood's
sixth draw
how is it possible and i said oh my god
i didn't even think about that the way
he plays the excitement
he gives during the game
i i was just about to forget that
actually he didn't win or lose any
single game no decisive game
but look what we have
petrol fabiano
fabiano uh no i i'm just looking there
did this really happen
rajav goes c5 a6
unexpected
very unexpected
if it really happened i need a i need a
visual confirmation
this is so rare and not supposed to be
very good if i play c3 or c4 or g3
the main point of this a6 move is after
d4 you can take
and now play knight f6 knight c3 e5
which is supposed to be fine
you stop knight db5 and then bishop b4
will come four knight f5 i guess t5
but
it's almost never seen at the top levels
because y is just supposed to be better
after c3
or here the other moves i mentioned
should that be a shocker
well at the same time people of course
they want to surprise each other
especially in case of fabiano i think
because he's considered
amongst also carlson the champion said
that he's the best prepared